all right so speaking about web security
in 2019 James
Romberg and good morning hello and
welcome thank you everybody for coming
I'm humbled and honored that you have
come to hear me talk about some stuff
let me start with telling you firstly
Who I am and why I've got something to
stay here so I've been doing web stuff
for a little while now 95 and I was
checking recently the content still
renders which is a testament to how well
browsers have maintained their
compatibility over time I got my first
paid gig doing web development then I
went on to become webmaster of my
University for a good couple of years
and I was sitting yesterday in Aaron's
talk on the was a leave a section of a
browser it was a great talk I do
recommend that you go back and watch the
story if you didn't catch it
I remember the Oz web conferencing Balor
in 1999 where about 40 people got
together it was probably all of the
people who've been doing web stuff
around that time and universities
talking about the standards and how they
were developing and what we were going
to be doing with the web I've been one
of the Debian Linux developers for her
goddess 18 years now I've done a bit of
time working in the finance industry so
the second picture up there was when I
ran LCI in oh three with some guy who
came over to visit us and I was just
thinking last night I've got a sort of
ten years later photo of a similar thing
at the moment I work for a printing
company in the UK and an advertising
company in the UK I returned to
Australia in 2010 with my little
souvenir called Oscar and we've been
back now for for nine years I've done a
stint working for a certain cloud
company who I've been here in Australia
a couple years as their security
solution architect across Australia in
New Zealand so I've actually spent a
fair bit of time in Auckland over a few
years delivering keynotes on security in
the cloud and right now I work as the
consulting director for a consulting
company across Australia in fact around
the world now they are called murders
who probably many of you have never
heard of but we do a lot of projects in
government statement federal government
and that's where I spend the last couple
of years and across all of that time
I've still been doing a bit of web stuff
in the background and there's been some
interesting things that have been
happening more recently which when you
look around and survey and a bit of
surveillance on what's out they find oh
my god there's a lot of stuff that
people have left turned on or they
haven't taken advantage of which they
easily could today so a little tour of
that but in the beginning ye old browser
evolved touched on recently yesterday
the one of the first browsers they're
not the very first was made by Tim
berners-lee which was the world wide web
browser as it was called or world one
web it was a browser and an editor in
one and obviously as Erin said yes they
did no images in it we moved on to
mosaic slightly after that which did
include images and then some of you in
this room might then remember this you
know I remember it all right there was a
certain line in there which actually was
Carly's interesting from a security
point of view it was that Wow
this was when SSL landed and the hope of
oh my god we could actually do something
secure over an untrusted insecure
Network however there was a there was a
barb in here anyone spot what the barb
is yeah international security which
means good yeah you know sadly meant
intentionally crippled and although
Aaron yesterday spoke about the browser
wars we also had the crypto Wars of
export grade cryptography where you
might have a 128-bit key but large
number of those bits were printed
plaintext every time was handed out so
that it could be intercepted so other
things have been happening a little bit
more recently we've been starting to see
a massive uptake in using HTTPS for
pretty much most of the web so telemetry
that's come from Firefox has shown that
this is hitting a high sort of 7080
percent now around the world and it's
looking like that trend is going to
continue all the way up to the point
that HTTP unencrypted will be removed
these days it's it's pretty much not
something you recommend for internal
external no matter where it is it's time
to actually move that off to encrypted
trusted end-to-end encryption so at the
same time as we've seen an uptick
in the amount of TLS or encrypted HTTP
traffic we've also seen the continuing
browser wars continue onwards and this
from stat counter is showing off is
eager for a chrome now hitting the sort
of the 65 70 percent of the market it's
really getting quite massive and in fact
you look at the browsers which are quite
modern you'll see something like 80 1.9
percent of them as of sort of this time
last night Oh yesterday was that's
what's being used in the wild we've got
quite modern browsers out there now to
touch on crime a little deeper one of
the best things about chrome is the fact
that you can pretty much rely on our
being up-to-date the crossover period
from an old version of Chrome to a new
version is about two to three months all
of those semi green lines that are cut
over a month or two and then drop down
again is chrome in the wild switching
from an older version to a new version
so that's pretty nice we know that we've
got quite modern browsers out there in
use we've also had an event where we've
had to get rid of older browsers which
don't support current levels of
cryptography and one of the biggest
events last year was from the 1st of
July where we had to have stronger
encryption for anything doing payment as
anybody here any ever paid a credit card
bill online everyone right so anytime
you've had a credit card number passed
across obviously it has to be subject to
very strict data handling and security
often mandated by the PCI or payment
card industry data security standard so
they introduced a new standard of this
in fact they introduced it back in about
2015 or 16 and most advancement that
looks good but way too soon it's gonna
be only a few years until we can get
there and so it was postponed a little
bit until the middle of last year and it
effectively told all of the cardholder
informants that they had to remove early
TLS which was very early and still
enabled on a lot of environments so what
this means between the auto-updating
browsers out there in the world and the
distribution of browsers by by vendors
and the PCI environment means that we're
now saying that the legacy browser has
really gone in the real world it's not
theoretical now it only sort of remains
in environments which have been
historically locked down in a managed
operating environment or
or standard operating run or anyone
operating under one of those yeah and
it's always behind and so the argument
or discussion I've had with a lot of
security teams in in public sector isn't
it has been do you know that the outside
world is more up-to-date on browser
technology than you are and have you
seen the list of security changes which
are in the newer version and why is your
policy to install the current - one
browser as opposed to the current one
where you are managing that environment
look at the additional known
vulnerabilities that you could already
be protected from so there's been a bit
of a mind shift in some agencies and
I've had some successes with some to
actually move them to a a much more
rapid uptake up to date with the rest of
the outside world
because there's a better security policy
for them so he led me on to given strong
requirements around security especially
some of the workloads I've dealt with
some of them have exceeded the
requirements around bank grade security
and wanting heard of bank grade security
yeah it's an awesome website go have a
look at it and then choose your bank
wisely it rates all of the banks by
security around the world what can we do
to improve security posture with this
little code as possible now I say as
little code as possible because
historically I've been I guess I would
have packed myself more with the SIS had
been rush than a developer brush but
everyone does a bit of both because it's
a brave new world and everybody wants
full sec so what can we do now with as
little actual code changes as possible
well it turns out there is a fair amount
and I'm going to take you through a list
of these things and what they actually
mean and what your risks would look like
and how easy these things are to do step
0 as I said is don't use HTTP a anymore
go to HTTPS there are free certificates
available which used to be one of the
old barriers and I would highly
recommend that if you've got a
non-production environment you should
get appropriate certificates in that
environment all the way from development
through tests through uit to production
if you can get certificates being issued
and handled correctly in development
you've got a far better chance of
getting it right in production and if
you can automate that even better
obviously using HTTPS it's not just
about how much you value your content
you might think that your content is
public of no security value
it's not holding credit-card information
but it's not about the data that you're
serving from your your side it's about
your visitors who are being intercepted
so who's used Wi-Fi in an airport so if
I turn on an access point right now
called maybe Qantas free Wi-Fi would you
connect to it probably there's a bunch
of interesting SS IDs you could set and
a large number of people to
automatically connect so you match you
want to wipe that as a as a network from
your phone so I'm using HTTPS Everywhere
internal-external and and all around the
place and as I said automating that
rollover certificates if you care of C
let's encrypt has been encouraging that
by having a very short 3-month we know
the browser see a forum which is the
industry body that the certificate
authorities are a member of has got
plans to reduce the maximum length that
a certificate can be should for so you
may remember that once upon a time you
get certificates for five years amazing
let's get that we won't have to do this
for another five years and what happens
after five years two things either you
can't remember or you're no longer there
whereas at least if it's automated it
continues to happen and also the CA has
the opportunity to issues stronger
certificates over time so I'm done
automation is really important you may
have seen recently that there's been a
number of websites across North America
where staff aren't there at the moment
to rotate those certificates so it's
been affecting a large number of places
with the furloughed workers of the
United States during their government
shutdown so anyway TLS protocols this is
the easy one there's a few versions I'm
going to take you through what they do
and some of you may know this some of
you it might be new some I'm not
pitching this at the very high end so
when you make a connection from your web
browser to a service provider at web
site the protocol is one of the first
things that gets initiated once you know
where that server is so after DNS
resolution etc the protocol is
organizing a key exchange and then bulk
encryption and there are two different
types of encryption that are used in
this one is asymmetric public key
private key encryption and then the much
longer how long you're a big fly aren't
you
right anyway and then there's the very
fast bulk encryption so bulk encryption
typically AES or something like that the
advanced encryption standard
quite often you'll find that that
algorithm is implemented in silicon in
the extensions of the CPU so it's
extremely fast it has one slight problem
that it's symmetric which means to
encrypt and decrypt the same key has to
be available on both sides across an
untrusted Network so clearly that first
bit the asymmetric public key
cryptography and read in the slide
that's actually computationally
expensive and slow so it's used to
transfer the key we're going to use and
obviously a few other parameters as well
so there are just 70 less versions out
there they did change name from being
called the secure socket library to the
transport layer security around the time
the IETF took our verse a stewardship of
the standard most of these are over ten
years old some of us have children that
are that age only six of these have ever
been used in the wild yes SSL version
one was so bad no one ever got a sword
see it three of them are not yet known
to be compromised and so the question is
do you have any of those enabled those
compromised ones this does your set on
your service that you operate or your
workplace or at any online service you
use does it support just those or does
it have some of those old ones still
enabled for compatibility and remember
the compatibility is the browsers we
aren't using anymore because they're
just not there in the wild zooming on
that tearless 1.1 the oldest of the
three that are left as we knock these
out of the ballpark little timeline of
some of the browser releases that have
happened over the two decades that we've
been at this TLS one three is quite knew
it was standardized in April of last
year of 2018 but there's that period
when TLS one one was the leading one in
2006 through 2008 it's a two-year period
and there really was only one browser
period in that release in that period
and only a few minor updates in fact you
hardly ever see any of those in the
water stalkers those those at Safari
releases the Safari is pretty much
updated most the time
so you are highly unlikely to see any
client using TLS 1.1 so you can probably
kill that out check it via your logs and
yes question oh goodness me I can't
remember where so when was can someone
use a search engine or something and
find out when we had ayah 9 it was a to
2011 okay so if you're still supporting
IE 9 which i think that's a chi probably
the low-water mark for a lot of people
today but yes you can probably written
but as i said check your logs if you're
not logging the protocol that is being
used for your connections you could
probably modify it get that and maybe
make a decision based on data as opposed
to guesswork no on the flip side your
stack probably doesn't support TX 1.3
yet so I can take it down a little bit
of other oh it's one of my previous
things I said was I am one of the Debian
developers there any other deities in
their own No ok fine so I've been
running Debian testing and yeah we've
got a reasonably recent version of
Apache in this her to 437 - 1 yeah as
I've lost not two dots ago was the
current package open SSL 1.1.1 ie and
you can do something like that in your
Apache configuration file and of course
you can do similar things in nginx et
cetera and that will give you the two
current protocols that are in use but
we've a big butt here but Marc Cox
posted this held that there was the
first important level security issue for
Apache to 437 came out so it's there's a
to 438 that's just been released it is
an amount of service that you can
trigger it and I've actually seen people
try and trigger that with remote
diagnosis tools that are supposedly
passive so anytime now there will be a
new version of Apache that fixes that in
there it's been a rough week for Debian
there's new version tapped out and
there's a new version of Debian out
today for Jessie just to fix apt which
has had a little bug with a redirection
problem anyway so coming back to it
protocol winners that you would want to
use today is TLS 1.2 from 2008
yes it's 11 years old and TLS 1.3 from
last year pre new but you should
definitely determine that from your logs
as to what you can get rid of all make
sense
easy yay ok let's all turn off unused
legacy protocols as a part of it ok so
which side of the network am I talking
about client-side service I didn't want
to say right inspired by QA do I know
no not just server-side you don't wanna
hurt second second guess yes you were
right but I was gonna say cloud side but
then both yes you probably shouldn't be
using those old protocols because they
can be compromised and so you probably
on the client side your staff your
colleagues your friends your family you
should probably try and get rid of it if
you've got proxy servers that you use it
maybe it's a corporate proxy egressing
out to the Internet you might want to
start to disable some of those older
proxies no ever any developers in the
room with us today anyone cut some code
good ok so the next thing one to look at
is if you're connecting to anything out
there and you think you're doing over
HTTPS you might want to look at which
protocols you're using there and there
is no cost rating protocols it's because
there's only 7 it's reasonably easy as
to which ones to choose but also some of
the newer ones get rid of a lot of other
configuration possibilities which are
actually really bad ideas so if you're
doing Java we got any Java people in the
room a few so if you want to get to TLS
1.2 where you could update Java 6 if
you're still there and there are a lot
of stuff out there still deployed on
Java 6 which will give you 2 units 1.2
support but it's pretty limited on the
encryption ciphers that we'll get to you
much better off upping to 7 or 8 and if
you're brave like some ups have been go
for Java 11 which includes TLS 1.3
support there was a release of 102 only
about a week ago for dotnet you can get
TLS 1.2 potentially in 4.5 net for point
some words it is default enabled however
there is no tearless one free support
yet it's waiting for the s channel D lor
one of the cryptographic providers
within Windows to support that for
Python Go Python 3 7 for PHP it just
passes straight down to the open SSL
library underneath and so the openness
is our library underneath it is 1.1 and
above ok what will on that nope not even
1.10 had to be 1.11 so let's get rid of
all of the probing languages and I'll
just tell you quickly where Debian was
up to on those versions so pretty much
Debian testing has got most of this
under control
so when it comes out as a state we're
releasing the phrase has just started
last week there's a soft freeze and
we'll be hopefully this year you should
be set to go on a lot of this now
talking about all of these older
protocols we as an industry have been
horrendous attorney this old stuff off
really really bad in fact a lot of
people will just turn everything that
looks like a tick box on it's got so bad
that the browser vendors themselves
actually cook together and collaborated
and simultaneously released an
announcement last year on October 15
saying well we'll take out the support
for these old protocols because you guys
aren't turning it off
similarly openness to sell as an
indicator that they're going to rip out
to support from their libraries for
older protocols over time because
reading them enabled is irresponsible
but it was pretty impressive to have
them all come together and put that
announcement now at the same time ok
let's have a little deeper cipher Suites
which looks like yelling with
underscores so I started pulling all
this part and although I've been doing
this for a while like it was only about
two years ago that I really started to
get any appreciation of what this
spaghetti meant so the key exchange we
talked about earlier that happens using
the really hard crypto at the beginning
of the transactions
once upon a time computers were a lot
slower than they were now and there used
to be a lot of key reuse if we had a
really good private key public key
sitting around don't bother
generating a new one just use the one
we've already got it's nice and quick
so that key exchange has been showing
that we can actually do something a lot
better
instead of using the same key over and
over again we can use a temporary key
which we throw away just for encrypting
this session now we've got still gonna
hand over our certificate to identify
who we are but that session key or an
ephemeral key means that you're
protected from that if anyone manages to
decrypt that session in the future
potentially every individual session has
used the new temporary key so
diffie-hellman became different
ephemeral the e on the end there is a
ephemeral but then a new implementation
was done using elliptical curves so
elliptical curves I won't draw it for
you but it's sometimes called the
billiard ball algorithm it uses the
expression of a curve in space and then
a starting point and somehow bounces off
the walls of that and ends up on a
destination it's effectively a trap door
function a one-way function to do some
of that encryption nicely it's a lot
more CPU efficient than diffie-hellman
which is nice it means it's faster which
means it can also be stronger at the
same level of computation far far
stronger so Murray is that new with
ephemeral mathematics being used in the
key exchange mechanism it's also being
used in the certificates themselves so
we've been using RSA certificates for a
long time so many of you will have
potentially generated a certificate once
upon a time with 512 bits in it and then
1024 bits and then the current standard
2048 bits you can see where this is
going except 4096 is incredibly slow
right now elliptical curve signatures
the ECDSA algorithm is again
significantly faster than RSA but gives
a similar or better cryptographic
strength but it's a new key signing
algorithm which means that you need a
new master certificate authority when
certificates are being issued so there's
a whole chain of changes again but we've
just been through this chain of changes
once upon a time we've signed
certificates using the md5 algorithm as
a hash or a thumbprint that got changed
over to sha-1 which got changed over
sha-256 as we've got two more unique
thumb prints so we wait for for CA is to
start to issue those and obviously we
want the entire chain from our
certificate to the root to have the same
strength it's not worth having a chain
with a weak link at any point
and we'll get new certificates soon so
bulk encryption AES has pretty much
become the standard so you may have come
across a es 128 and 256 anyone's seen
that when they've looked at the crypto
know if you do don't be don't think that
256 is stronger than 128 it's a block
chained algorithm the 128 means I'm
gonna encrypt 128 bits at a time or 256
bits at a time it's not that as twice as
strong now it does pad that block so if
the block isn't full it'll fill it up so
it is exactly 128 bits or 256 bits and
then it changed those blocks together so
that they're all individually unique
with a new initialization vector for
each block and there's a mode or several
modes of chaining those blocks together
you use the output from the first block
as the input to the second and what do
you use for the third one is at the
second one or is that the second plus
the first or all kinds of inverter we're
doing that and there's a motive they're
called Gala's counter mode anyone heard
of GCM a few yeah okay so let me give
you the other aside which I didn't put
in here Galois was a French
mathematician who was imprisoned in the
Bastille and he escaped when the
Bastille was stormed which is went 14th
of March is it when is Bastille Day
sorry July thank you anyway he was a
mathematician anyone here a
mathematician no yes one okay so
mathematicians he was killed in a duel
over a woman is like you don't see
that's quite an interesting thing to
happen to a man he was only 20 but
anyway this was the 1800s and GCM is
currently the only known method of
chaining blocks together that is still
secure because her friends and Microsoft
came out with an announcement last year
that said CBC mode which was the gist
chain one to the other to the other to
the other much stuff no longer believes
it's safe to decrypt data that has been
encrypted with the CBC mode except in
very specific circumstances I didn't
want to limit myself to very specific
circumstances so I use GCM for pretty
much everything I do
and that's probably a safe reason to be
to do as well but it does mean that
Microsoft Internet Explorer we're not
running on Windows 10 cannot do secure
encryption so it's it's worth probably
telling people that you shouldn't
support IE 9 or 10 anymore
um go 11 go edge and obviously the the
more modern browsers out there you've
also already got the TLS problem that IE
9 doesn't support TLS 1.2 like I tell
you I had to go a new neighborhood it's
like why anyway moving on some of those
check sums that happen inside TLS so
fingerprint algorithms that you have
come up with moving to Chartres 56 some
newer browsers support longer check sums
but obviously they're a little bit more
computationally intensive so depending
on how much traffic you're serving you
may want to stay with char 256 for the
moment and maybe as a standby give
people ability to use char 3 or 4 or 5
12 there are new check some algorithms
coming one is called Blake and a bunch
of others interestingly we know that
char 256 how big it looks you've all
seen check sums recently there Blake
algorithm lets you apply an arbitrary
length to your fingerprint algorithm so
take this data and give me a 64-bit
checksum or a 65 bit checksum or a 1024
bit checksum it's up to you how long you
want that so that's all pretty
interesting and that's generally just
configuration on a web server or a
client anything with the TCP stack or
your own code that you're writing
outbound now I'm getting back to
browsers specifically because we've got
new modern browsers we can influence and
restrict what the browser can and can't
do now it won't work at every browser
but we've seen the majority of them can
so we could actually increase the
security posture there and one of the
first ones is the strict Transport
Security header it's really simple it
effectively says please remember to make
secure requests to this service by
default so if somebody types in the URL
by hand without a protocol specification
where the default current needs to do
unencrypted HTTP the browser will go
hang on I already know I visited that
site before and made a good connection
last time and I was told to remember
that so I'm gonna go actually DPS
straight away pretty simple in Apache
you said it a number of seconds that's a
year
effectively it's a guarantee that I'm
not going back to unencrypted HTTP on
this site if I stuff up my keys I'll get
fresh ones easy enough
next one content security policies
content security policies allows you to
place limits around the resources that
the browser is going to load what source
am i allowing for images now you
probably think you're gonna serve images
from your own service or a CDN but if
you've got a JavaScript that suddenly
loads images from a third party location
you can block the browser from loading
them so it looks something like that
so allow default from none very
interesting I don't want any content
except I'll allow image sources from
self the site this content security
policy was loaded from from data which
is base64 encoded images in cascading
style sheets that's script source from
self interesting the unsafe inline it's
an interesting opinion they've got there
that means JavaScript embedded in the
page as the post of JavaScript loaded
from an external URL so there's quite a
strong indication there they don't trust
JavaScript being put in the page when
they've made this is a w3c
implementation by the way there's a
number of levels or revisions of content
security policy we currently have
revision two enabled there is a revision
three coming there are more and more
controls or constraints being put around
what the browser can do over time
including frame source and and sess the
source is another one so if you've got
any one two frames no frames yeah a few
people yeah friends considered evil yes
except sometimes you're forced to and if
you have a frame in your page from a
third party side what's to stop them
from putting a frame that loads from
somewhere else it's it's Turtles at that
point well you can actually limit that
you can say I'm only going to allow a
frame from a comm and nowhere else and
even if a comm frames be calm it won't
load you'll actually be able to block it
likewise you can say only allow me to be
framed in nowhere I do not wish to be
framed so if somebody tries to frame you
it won't render in the browser
definitely worth looking at they cannot
show you with an example that I use in a
moment but let me
on referral policies so the browser
often gives a refer of the page that
previously browsed and we use that for
anyone tracking very good yes once upon
a time analytics but nobody uses app
analytics these days we do analytic fire
what Google Analytics these days maybe
other parties out there so the referrer
has basically become undesirable
especially if it's got path information
it might actually be a security
disclosure like user ID equals as a
query string if that's pulled across so
you can actually turn off that you tell
the browser don't bother sending me the
referrer and if you're a really busy
website saving a couple of kilobytes per
request might be quite useful or you can
say whether it's between origins or pars
or if I go from this site to another
site strip off the path and just leave
the hostname there's some really
interesting options you may not have to
have hostname referrers because you
might have another service that you
integrate with who needs to see that
refer future policies this is really
nice stuff so you probably have a device
in your pocket which has a web browser
in it and that device can probably
vibrate it can probably make a lot of
noise more importantly it can say where
you are and JavaScript can get to that
information but with a feature policy
you could disable it and say geolocation
no ways allowed to access that so even
if you're depending upon third-party
JavaScript like for example Google
Analytics if Google Analytics was
updated to say all go and get the user's
geolocation information it would be
blocked there is a long list of things
on this that you can block or enable or
limit that it's only JavaScript loaded
from the same web site or from my CDN or
a trusted location but nowhere else some
older ones X content types no sniff this
is when the serve content doesn't match
the mime type so mime types describe hey
this image it's an image of JPEG there
are some servers out there that would
happily serve an image called text plane
and a lot of the code that's been in
historical browsers has been to deal
with misconfigurations
of service here we actually added option
to say don't try and double guess the
content if my content type is wrong
please break strictly don't guess that
something's JavaScript when it shouldn't
be that someone's tried to give me an
image which contains JavaScript so this
is an example of a policy or set of
headers I add into Apache on one of my
services you can see they can get quite
detailed including you know where can
Ajax requests xhr requests go off to and
I have got I will tell you just go to
w3c and all the information is there
including some of the newer stuff that's
coming through so gyroscopes speakers
and vibrate fullscreen ability what
we're talking about headers oh there's
one other thing I wanted to say is that
please stop telling people what you're
running it's totally unnecessary it
makes it really easy just to go and look
up a threat list and go hello ie10 right
well I'll start with this one
get rid of versions if you can get rid
of the whole header if you can't even
better okay CAA so um the certificate
authorities are given evidence as to
when they can issue a certificate in and
that with a name and that evidence
sometimes is a secret that is left in
DNS a key whose value and keep one of
the risks is that there's a large number
of certificate authorities in the world
who are pre-installed on every browser
and every device you've got around 200
or more screenshot on the right there is
from Android P last night you can turn
some of these off if you wish you don't
have to trust them that they are just
pre installed by default and by default
they're all enabled including things
like Taiwanese Internet Authority Hong
Kong Post and a lot of others about
these certificate authorities are
members of the certificate see a browser
forum I should say and to remain a
member they have to follow a code of
conduct a baseline requirements of what
they do however you can now actually
inform the CAS who's authorized on your
behalf to issue a certificate so that if
somebody else was thought to somehow
come
it's a CA hey Hong Kong post my name is
google.com please give me a certificate
there's now a mechanism that those CAS
are required since September of 2017 to
check in the DNS to see if there is an
authorization resource record type that
lists who your authorized CIA's are and
to block issuance if they are not issued
listed as a identify so it's really easy
and it's supported in a large number of
places now effectively if you were to
put that into that domain as a record at
the top it would mean everything
recursively under that could only have
certificates issued by let's encrypt you
can limit whether it's wild card
certificates or explicitly named
certificates set the record forget it
the only time it's looked up is when a
CA is about to issue a certificate it's
not highly used which means you could
probably set a really low case time on
it so if you start to use a new CA and
it's wrong don't change the record go
back and redo it don't set it for a week
or a month you could set it for 30
seconds if you wanted to okay DNS SEC
aside number 100 yeah I wasn't going to
mention that we don't have DNA second
cover you but hey New Zealand well done
on having signed designs for gov CO and
Albany and said it's really good to see
you've had that since 2012 oh my god
okay clearly this is good but there are
also bad times
for DNS SEC one of which came up
yesterday certain domains are
disappearing from the internet at the
moment because people aren't refreshing
their keys because they haven't
automated see that earlier point yeah
it's kind of just not good so I ad I
disappeared yesterday it's part of the
NSA for their information assurance and
ironically then not online at the moment
that tool is called dear DNS fees as
well which shows you signing of DNS so
we've kind of suddenly could held off to
DNS for a moment but there's interesting
stuff happening there too okay back up
into the web sub resource integrity
version locking those external
dependencies do you want to stop any
modifications to a third party hosted
javascript image whatever that happens
to be
if it's google analytics maybe not you
might trust their security policy to
always be up to date for others maybe
you want to so there was an issue that
happened last year whereas a piece of
code that was used for usability on our
whole bunch of government websites was
modified at its shared source and
injected something called coin hive js2
an unknown wallet
The Fixer this was pretty simple you
could just take a checksum and add it
into the what area yes they called the
MU tag or image or the script source and
that basically locks it it does mean you
probably want version numbers in the
file name because any change to that
script will stop it from executing so
there's increased maintenance but it
means it's less likely to be modified
cool moving on cookies everyone's heard
of cookies yeah so cookies been around
for a long time I went to the voice
they're old they've been there for a
long time obviously the state
informational session information in
them and there's some flags that you can
put on cookies when you set them in the
browser say hey this cookie it's secure
don't serve it over HTTP and when we
cool things if you forgot to serve that
secure flag on our cookie but you've got
the HSTs flag you're protected because
the browser won't leak the cookie as
well so socks and shoes basically
everything up but there is a new flag
and the new flag is called the same site
from 2016 you may find that not a lot of
environments support this yet it
effectively says either in mode strict
or lacks then if I'm on this site and I
go to this site and I already had a
session cookie here so for example
Facebook LinkedIn Google whatever if I'm
in strict mode don't serve the cookie
when I land on the destination of a
hyperlink make it look like I'm not
logged in the lacs mode similar it only
does it when the source was a post to
the destination so it stops cross-site
request forgery that you get tricked
into saying you know with a free TV
click here and it's a post with hidden
fields that goes across to Facebook and
says I really like this TV manufacturer
or whatever happens to me now one thing
you might want to do is inject that into
the headers that are being served out
from your
see if your library's supported but it
does give you a little bit of extra
security few users and it's really
really simple as I said you just add the
header to the end yeah quite
straightforward right I'm running out of
time so I'm gonna see a beat up turn on
htv-2 so xv2 it's been out for a while
it's a binary wire protocol it's
slightly more efficient then what's come
before it compresses headers and it does
true multiplexing whereas h-2b 1.1 used
to go 1 request that if you had keeper
lives turned on you get a response and a
second request in series actually to
true multiplexing I want this this this
is thisis ok that one's ready that one's
really that one's ready so it's a lot
faster I was going to do a demo but I'm
gonna skip it but it's true parallel I'm
running out of time Akamai has a nice
demo which shows you loading about 200
images in a little diagram and it's
depending on the time you'll see it's
much faster and it is possible on 2.4
with Apache port on Debian in testing
you just specify your protocols and
there's a nice little header that says
oh by the way if you're using HTTP to
only use those modern TLS protocol so
there's another a little bit of extra
that fixes that up but if you've got
subversion loaded with more dev there's
a seg fault that happens so it's not me
that's good
however there is a fix so a few days ago
there was an update to that and there's
a hell of a lot more we can do so
there's new compression algorithms to
look at there's error reporting from the
browsers that you can do say if you have
an error don't be silent about it report
that error to my error logging service
over here so you can find out what the
clients are saying mu key exchange
mechanisms such as what Google has
started with quantum safe key exchanges
so that's the main money shot of there's
a whole bunch of stuff to go do a whole
bunch of interesting stuff that I think
will give you a better security posture
faster delivery to your client with
almost zero code changes the last one I
was going to say is on Wednesday in
which there was a busy day for security
as well there were six US government
departments that had their DNS domains
hijacked by allegedly Iranian actors and
u.s. cyber security and infrastructure
security agency director Chris Krebs
not our curbs that we would know from
security
that they should order DNS records
change DNS accounts add multi-factor and
add transparency logging and reviewing
this the transparency logging has been a
requirement for certificate authorities
force on time every time you get a cert
they write to public locations Facebook
has a free service you can sign up to
you put in your domain name and they
will mail you every time they see a new
certificate for your domain you tick a
box and they will mail you every time
they see a certificate issued for
something that looks like a fish of your
domain name if you put in apple.com oh
my god you'll see everything out there
so the summary if you're a sis that mean
please go update your services not just
web IMAP SMTP whatever you have this
listing developers if you're writing
code and using a web client please limit
how far back on your protocols you're
gonna support it's the easiest thing to
do certain libraries that I think in not
actually it's PHP there's a library you
can use that will actually specify the
minimum protocol for you and anything
above if you're DevOps then do all the
rest than everything else for more
information there's a bunch of really
interesting people
Troy hunt is up in the Gold Coast's got
home in the UK
Ivan ristic Hardin eyes check their
sites there's a lot of good information
out there that's floating around by
reducing the number of things that
you're doing and offering and supporting
you're probably reducing your risk and
as far easy to keep track of any changes
to them when there's less things to look
at
that's my details I said at the start I
worked for modis and we're hiring if
anybody wants conan hack on any of this
stuff and work on this and try and fix
up our customers environments reach out
to me come talk to me thank you very
much your time we'll just say some
questions
gay Paul you talked at the beginning
about your symmetric-key algorithms I
have heard that there's still some
debate really regarding the use of
elliptic curve and a lot of more
traditional crypto folks are much more
comfortable with RSA can you speak to
that in terms of who to listen to what
what issues are around that so I've been
taking a lot of information from the
resources that I had above and
especially with showed that here if you
use SSL labs or Observatory silicon I've
been using their distilled knowledge to
test services that I'm running and see
how they rate them and they've been
waiting
GCM higher than than other
implementations
they've been rating elliptical curve
higher I haven't seen anything myself
about elliptical curve not being as
reliable as what I think of well I may
be wrong so I'd definitely encourage you
to have a look around I can't give you a
definite answer on that it's only
recently that I've seen that split where
the elliptical curve has been weighted
higher than other things but there's a
lot going on in that especially
obviously with the quantum stuff
starting to come out in IBM I think he's
been doing a lot on Connor competing and
speaking at this conference about some
of the stuff they've been doing it's
definitely an area that is changing a
lot so I could give you a better answer
but I'm not sure it's it's definitely a
pretty busy yay all right
you mentioned Bank grade security if you
go there you get a single static page
that says as of November 2018 this
project has been suspended so please
don't send people here in your talk okay
thank you
it was a good site probably said that
once about Geocities but anyway it used
to write banks on their corporate comms
front page home page who cares but it
also used to doing this assessment of
their internet banking services and
which of these things that they turned
on turned off and give them a score so
you could rate them but that's a shame
hmm yes next thing
I you mentioned that modern browsers are
supporting a TLS 1.2 and above and we
should not really carry about everything
that is older because it's not there and
that's true for for a desktop browsers
there is still quite a lot of old phones
especially in effort our world countries
and over there there was a huge problem
in K so especially with ciphers the most
of them supports TLS 1.2 but the ciphers
is like really bad which is why it's
worth turning on logging or adjusting
your login if you've never looked at me
most of us are probably aware of an
access log basic hit log modified to
include the protocol and cipher being
used if you see the protocols and
ciphers being used work out where
they're coming from and why you're
having it it could be it could be coming
from another country which doesn't have
those ciphers available it could be
coming from an old integration service
that you've forgotten about written in
Python 1 still working yeah but probably
needs some maintenance because it's not
being touched Android 4 yeah absolutely
but then you've got to look at and
assess this you've got a way up is it
worth still supporting Android 4 what
are you actually doing you accepting
credit card information do you need to
be PCI compliant then you can make that
judgment call are you doing something
that's more important than credit card
information well then it's probably a
good idea to follow PCI's minimum
recommendations because they've got a
reasonably good idea as to why not it's
all the exploits that have happened
around Moodle and the rest it's a tough
decision to be in you've got it in a
cell with the security team go what are
we going to be strict on this or can we
have backward compatibility and that
might change depending on whether it's
your corporate web comms or an
integration API endpoint these things
are going to change over time
it's stepping-stones and unfortunately
we've left every other stepping-stone
behind us we do need to start to pick
some of them up and wait for the new
ones to come through so I think it's a
good point but work on data next yes
what's the preferred method for getting
H new PS in places there let's encrypt
can reach like some stuff not on the
probably Internet so you're talking
about where the con
name the domain name is not in the
public dns yeah you could establish your
own CA there are scripts to do this all
over the place using open SSL for free
you can establish the CA issue that
private CA public certificate to your
environment and then put a certificate
onto your service there's a lot of
automated scripts to do that yes for
better way yes please like value there's
a better way to do that our internal
certificate automation tool uses
dns-based records that are present in
the external DNS to authenticate the
keys that it's creating for internal
sites so they they've got an alternate
mechanism now that you can use without
needing to expose something to the
public on behalf of everyone has a small
token of our appreciation let's give it
one big
[Applause]